what sort of actionable tips can you
give to guys watching this right now
that might be
dealing with anxiety when it comes to
the view that they have of themselves
the view they have of women
how women might respond to them you know
like
a lot of guys even have issues with
money like they don't think that they're
entitled to
earn money or to charge people money for
doing work like they feel like they're
ripping them off if they don't
actually give them something physical
and they give them a service
i had a i had a call earlier today with
a guy that had this idea like this big
business idea for creating this
um i'm not going to get into the details
but base
basically it was a green product and he
was going to go ahead and complicate his
entire
life building out this uh product i'm
not a big fan of it if you guys are on
my email list by the way you should have
gotten an email from me on sunday
uh from a learning event from friday
telling you guys exactly what not to do
in business but
there was a lot of things in here that
he was trying to structure into the
business
and one of the sticking points that he
had was i
prefer to build a physical product or to
sell a physical product
because i feel like i am that i'm
deserving
of the income that i earn from that
versus something that's a digital
product or a service based product
because he didn't feel like he was able
to charge for the value that he would
create even though it's not tangible
like something you can physically
touch a lot of people have reservations
in many areas of their life so
i guess it is still that big long blab
down to something is what kind of actual
information can you give guys that they
can take away at least from watching the
show today
that they can apply in their lives right
now
so the short version is if you're
running up to to issues like that if
there's
places in your life where you're running
into a wall
that's a sign that there's something
going on deeper inside that you need to
take a look at
that's number one whether that is just
not being able to take action
on whatever it is you're trying to do
whether that's a refusal
to accept something like being able to
accept uh you know compensation for a
digital project
or a service based product instead of a
physical one that's a sign that there's
something going on deep inside
that's blocking you from that that's a
sign that there's a belief that's
holding you back from doing that
and it's probably a good idea to stop
take a pause and start looking at that
in whatever way you choose
meditation is really good for stuff like
this if you just become more aware of
what's going on inside you your emotions
and your thoughts that's definitely
going to give you a bit more
uh a bit more insight right journaling
works on a regular basis
if you're just journaling down your
thoughts it's going to start process
it's going to start prompting that
unconscious part of your brain to start
offering up
more insight into what you're going what
you're going through what's going on
that's one of the big reasons why
journaling is a powerful thing
but other than that yeah it does come
down to working with somebody who
knows how to dig in your head whether
that's traditional therapist whether
that's a hypnotist whether it's a coach
right because it's going to be very
difficult to get there on your own
because of that barrier because of that
critical factor is generally trying to
protect you from something
if your unconscious mind is trying to
protect you from something it's also not
going to show you it
because it thinks it's going to hurt you
if it does
that's why therapy can take so long is
it kind of has to walk you down that
path
piece by piece make non-threatening move
by non-threatening movement by
non-threatening move until you can
finally get down
to that deeper stuff and that could be a
very long difficult process
i think that this is much faster i think
the point a lot of guys overlook is the
whole journaling thing that's
that's uh i mean i've found a lot of
benefit myself
um i've journaled stuff in business i've
journaled business ideas
if um if you follow guys like james
altucher they talk about using that part
of your mind it's like a muscle and an
atrophies if you don't
you know creatively keep coming up with
ways to solve things in the world in
your
day-to-day lives i've journaled dates
you know i had a a
a dating journal it's like you know you
kind of go through the process while
you're spinning plates that like break
down like all your thoughts post out
you know posts and you know um approach
for
for follow-up you know the sort of uh
the sort of ideas that you come up with
after the fact to get them out of your
head and down on
on paper like especially if you have an
active mind at night a lot of guys can't
sleep because they're [ __ ] mind just
it's like running at 9000 rpm and it's
like journaling gets a lot of stuff out
of your head and onto paper and you'll
be surprising how therapeutic it can
actually be
oh absolutely absolutely and that's why
you know i always i keep my bullet
journal around
like this bad boy right here just so as
things pop up during the day that i need
to do they go in here things that i
think of that come up during the day
they go in here like i just review this
stuff
every single day morning and night
whenever i get up in the morning i take
a look at what i've
written down to do the day before ads
whatever else i need to add in there
yeah write down whatever thoughts i'm
having at the end of the day go back
over what i've done
you know what progress have i made to my
goals what streams have i added to what
obstacles have i overcome
what new came up that i need to start
taking a look at because that's a big
thing
you don't even need a a written journal
you can get evernote you know as an app
on your phone and it syncs with a laptop
or anything else i mean you can
literally journal that way too
you